[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and if you left
yoga feeling like he needed the Maury
show to carry out a paternity test
then this is the video for you
throughout I'm gonna be answering one of
the biggest mysteries surrounding the
film which is was Arthur really Thomas
Wayne's son this question carries a lot
of weight with it and if true then it
means that Batman and the Joker half
brothers it feels like a plot point rips
straight out of the Austin Powers series
however there's also the potential that
Arthur's mother could be making it all
up
and throughout I'll be weighing up the
fours and against to let you know what
the truth behind the entire thing is
there will of course be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
watch Joker yet and don't want the
results of the DNA test spoil for you
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now without the way I just want to
give a huge thank you for clicking this
video now let's get into our breakdown
over whether Thomas Wayne is the father
or not
okay so Joker follows off Affleck a
struggling clown that wants to become a
stand-up comedian but he seems to be
beaten down by Gotham City at every
possible opportunity
black lives with his mother a woman that
in her youth worked for the Wayne's
before seemingly being let go because of
her obsession with Thomas the households
owner and future mayoral candidate now
this is definitely 100 percent true as
not only do we have it confirmed by
Alfred at the gates of Wayne Manor
but Thomas himself it's one of the major
aspects in the story that is
corroborated so we can take penny at a
word on this one so yeah one point to
penny she did indeed work at Wayne Manor
however why she wasn't that goal it's
the first point of contention as the
Wayne staff and Thomas himself say that
she's crazy now where things start to
unravel is over whether Thomas and penny
actually did have a relationship
together if they did then this means
that Thomas framed an adoption for the
child so that he would be completely
disconnected from it and then made penny
look like she was crazy so that she
would be locked up and sent to Arkham if
this is the case and no one would ever
believe her and Thomas would get away
with it all scot-free we get a brief
hint
Thomas and Penny did indeed have a
relationship together when arthur
discovers a photograph of his mother
when she was younger that is signed with
the initials TW this is deliberately
left ambiguous but from this I take it
that Thomas and Penny were indeed
sleeping together if we take Arthur's
mother at around the age of 60 to 70 and
Arthur at 40 and it does appear that she
did work around the property at the age
in the photo and therefore the TW that
she would have known at this time would
have been Thomas the fact that Alfred
can also instantly recall a worker who
hasn't been at the Manor for over there
yes signifies to me at least that she
must have been important so point you to
penny but that doesn't mean that she got
pregnant with Thomas's child and is the
fact that they instantly recalled her
just because Thomas has had recent
dealings with her well we do know that
penny wished to send a letter to Thomas
and the heart that discovered it and
lynnandhev is apparently Asian however
this may not have been the first letter
that penny sent and in the bathroom when
Arthur conference Thomas one of the
first things that the billionaire asks
is what do you want is it money this
highlights to me that penny has already
been writing to Thomas and asking him
for cash which is why so quick to ask it
Alfred in the film is also portrayed to
be in his mid to late 40s which probably
adds a lot of credence to the fact that
he's too young to have been working at
the manor at the time therefore he may
only know about penny due to her recent
actions so point one to Thomas Thomas
also at this point states that she has a
narcissistic personality disorder or NPD
for short people with NPD have a
long-term pattern of exaggerated
feelings of self-importance an excessive
need for admiration and a lack of
empathy towards other people we
definitely know this is the case with
penny as we learn that she was complicit
in the abuse of Arthur as he was growing
up add that to the fact she keeps
talking about how Arthur is Thomas's son
and never once mentions the adoption so
she could just be over exaggerating
about their relationship so point two to
Thomas now that's all of the evidence in
the film pretty much and he left with
the two possibilities either Thomas is
the father and he covered it up or penny
is trying to extort him in order to
money with it being a tie it's time to
look outside of the movie and see what
evidence we have from the people who
worked on the film and so on
when discussing his betrayal with The
Hollywood Reporter Brad Cullen who plays
Thomas in the film said the following on
the matter the film delves into Thomas
Wayne and more we tackle the idea that
if you're a successful businessman then
there are certain things you do to have
that success and sometimes those things
on a prey sometimes that cutthroat I
think there's a real edge to him he's
very much based in reality I went to
Todd and asked are we playing this the
way that they were playing it and Todd
responded with what would be a
compelling reason for the Joker to hate
Batman so much the idea that the Joker
is an illegitimate child that didn't get
anything from the Wayne family is a very
compelling motivation for his characters
hatred so it definitely seems like
killing himself thinks that he is the
father of Arthur so one more point to
Penny and the final point which I'll
leave up to you to interpret is the fact
that dante pereira olson who plays bruce
wayne and joker also played a younger
version of joaquin phoenix and you were
never really here on the surface at the
very least it does seem like todd cast
the actor in order to draw on the fact
that they have some resemblance and
Arthur even remarks in the movie that he
and Thomas look alike so weighing
everything up and know it's meant to be
ambiguous but if I had to choose a side
I would say that Thomas is indeed the
father he did have a relationship with
penny when he was younger and I believe
that he framed not only the adoption but
also her mental illness the fact that
penny and Arthur both had the same
mental condition adds a lot of weight to
the thinking that they are both indeed
related and if this is the case and it
adds more weight to the fact that he is
Thomas's child due to the relationship
that we know that the two had whilst we
will never categorically get a yes or no
answer to me I definitely think the
clues are there to draw the conclusion
that Thomas is Arthur's real father and
that Joker in this universe is indeed
tied to Batman closer than we think now
obviously I would absolutely love to
read your thoughts on this and I'm sure
that everyone is going to have their own
opinion on the matter what's great about
yoga is there's
really no right or wrong answer so make
sure you leave your opinion on who the
daddy is in the comment section below if
you enjoyed this video then please like
it and make sure you check out my band
theory that all of the events in the
movie was simply in Arthur's head I go
over the evidence to support it as well
as the key pointers so it's definitely
worth checking out if you want to know
more you want to come chat to me on
Twitter about movies TV shows games and
comic books and make sure you follow me
at definition whitey it's the best place
to keep up to date with the channel and
if you want to join our discord then
make sure you click the link in the
description below we've got an awesome
community and talk theories spoilers
reviews and more with people just like
you so definitely make sure you join us
over there I also just wanna let you
know that we're currently giving away a
free copy of spider-man far from home on
blu-ray and all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning is to like this
video make sure that you subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts on
who Joker's father is in the comment
section below
the winner will be chosen at random on
October the 15th and the blue arrow be
shipped out from mentor get surprised
it's the best of luck that everyone who
takes part this is a channel for people
who are super into superheroes so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you